[Music]
now the raiders
and the entire nfl having to make a
whole lot of adjustments this year with
fears over coronavirus
ron futrell joins us now with the latest
now one of the more significant issues
seven weeks into this nfl season has
been
teams dealing with the covet 19 crisis
the personal part of it certainly is the
most significant but games have had to
be rescheduled lives disrupted
and the sports books have had to adopt
their own game plan
but it does make it difficult for us you
know with all these cancellations
the flip side which is kind of uh you
know making the glass half full
as we get sometimes that we get double
headers on monday nights we get
tuesday night football so you gotta take
the good with the bad i guess
also this week ben mgm announced that
they are offering a hundred dollar bonus
when you sign up for the app
just in time for the raiders against the
bucks it's a very exciting number one to
have tom brady come in here to
for sunday night football the money has
come in so far on
tampa bay we opened them up at three
it's gone
up to three minus 120 so you know we
will be rooting for the raiders
so here we go we've got the return of
the pirate bowl here to legion stadium
that's the raiders against the
buccaneers
a rematch of the super bowl from 2003
down in san diego
buccaneers won that game big their head
coach at the time
of course john gruden chucky now with
the raiders
at allegiance stadium ron futrell
reporting eight sports now